and welcome my name is andreas fatigue
and I work as an urban trainer
consultant and occasional speaker and
I'm also the creator of C++ insights
which is the topic of the talk today so
I'm really happy to talk about the
program before we dive into the program
or C++ let me tell you should story
about my name I'm doing this for quite a
while now
my last name is fetish and in German
that's an adjective in English it can be
translated to finish finish or completed
for example there is also made aware
about dad at NEC Oslo there is in region
spelling for it which is pronounced Fadi
so I learned that I now also know that
be honest roadtrips is at least able to
read German because he understood that
my last name means finish in German the
adjective is spelled with lower first
letter because it's an adjective if I
type my name it starts with a capital F
so I constantly fight with the spell
checker whether I'm right or the spell
checker is right it's a fight I cannot
win so anyway it's hard for the spell
checker we are here today because of C++
and this piece of code should be the
motivation or one motivation for why I
created C++ in sides these are two lines
of code I have something here called my
type I create an object out of it called
I to appraise default initialization and
then I post increment I post
incrementing is maybe not as efficient
as pre-incrementing and when I'm
teaching I try to encourage people to
use pre in command as often as they can
and post increment only if it's really
needed
and then they ask questions especially
if I'm lecturing what's the difference
in why just from this example you cannot
tell because my type can either be in a
layer student was some other building
trivial type then it makes no real
difference whether you do a post or pre
increment my tap can also be a class
type which implements operate a plus
plus and then it makes a difference
because in that operator I have to
create a temporary and they have to
create a deep copy of the object before
if it's holding a large or huge stood
string
it cost me memory it costs me time so it
makes a difference but I cannot tell and
then students ask me where I cannot see
it
and then I say ok look at this it's I
dot operator plus plus in parens 0 0 is
because it's the post increment the
increment comes without a parameter
that's the only difference so if I can
show things to people I at least myself
can teach it a little better and in my
experience they understand it a little
better
another example is this program short
program and implement a max function
that returns to create a value of either
A or B and then prints that out with a
printf question number one what is the
output of this program
guesses one exactly one is the output of
this program because we are looking at
integer promotion and implicit casts we
cannot see them we use them often in C++
they are not necessarily bad in my
opinion but we cannot see them this is
the website of C++ insights you can use
it either at a website or you can
install it locally and run it as a Linux
or Mac command and I have here the
example from the slide and if I now
transform it then we can see oh the code
the compiler sees or uses is slightly
different
there are implicit costs if you look at
a max function then we first can see a
and B are promoted to signed int because
there is no comparison of two shorts in
just a smallest type that's comparable
so it will be promoted to rent but
that's not the part with which might
sauce here there's another integer
promotion the return value of Max which
is also short is also promote the TuneIn
when it's passed to printf and then if
here another static cast casting my
unsigned short which is a huge short
before into a sign short it makes it a
negative one and that's why one in this
case is greater than 65 K it makes it
easier for me to explain things if I can
show them then not just have to use
words I can show it I can show what's
changing
if I remove for example this unsigned
here first I get now a compiler warning
and the cost here has gone away of
course there's no reason to cost it
anymore
so these are one or two reasons why I
created C++ insights the idea here is
that the tool should show what is going
on under the hood what lovely sings the
compiler does for us just to make it
easier for us to write code because the
implicit costs I showed you earlier
they're not bad necessarily in that
example they bidders but in other places
they spare us typing so in general they
are good but making invisible things
visible can help when teaching the Eric
goal is C++ insights should it generate
valid code if possible that's for two
reasons one I can test valid code so I
can verify that the output at least
compiles that's not total garbage mmm
there are still possibilities that it
does not do the right thing but at least
it compiles the second thing is
imaginary code is nice but I have a
really huge imagination and it doesn't
help anybody
I should write so I find novels but if I
come up with something very made-up in
C++ that wouldn't help so that's why to
create well it code out of it it means
also to create of course code that
compiles the program itself it's it's
open source can forked or submit github
pull requests and you've already seen
the website while we are here I think
it's also words to talk a little bit
about limitations of the program because
if you're using it you I think
shall know about it C++ insights uses
the nice and lovely infrastructure of
clang it's a clang tool but has the nice
side effect
I do not need to parse C++ code myself
which is of course Trevor tasks but it
was nice and I didn't have to learn it's
not so true at all that also implies
that everything it shows is how clang
does things GCC might do things a little
different there's room in the standard
for interpretation they can be bright
both the well at implementation but it
may differ a little if you are using the
release version
I don't know website or the command-line
tool then this compiles on the Linux
against lips did C++ while the Mac
version compiles against lip C++ looking
at certain things of this under library
you will see differences there for
example how they implemented stood
string or things like that so this build
look slightly different still works and
so on
but it's worth noting the the release
version as well as the web version are
based on clang stable the latest clang
stable version available gets to half a
stable codebase to compile C++ insights
again and to make issue reporting and
resolving issues easier the source
itself had tried to maintain in a way
that it's up to date with clang current
so we already have patches to enable
clang 9 support which will bring us some
of the C++ 20 features for lambdas for
example clang line is a little bit
behind schedule right now it was
supposed to be released in end of August
but I think we will have it in a couple
of days or so what C++ insights does is
it uses the clang ast so the already
processed C++ program the abstract
syntax tree clang generates and
transforms that back into C++ code as
this ast is generated at an early stage
in the front-end
you will not see any effects of
optimization so it doesn't make a
difference where are you passing - oh
cero or - all three - the program
because most of these optimizations
happen afterwards you will however see
simple things you're in in some cases
constraints peer evaluation if it's
possible in an early stage are a simple
sayings trivial things like building the
sum of three plus four is something
you'd affront and thus while walking
through the code basically so these are
the things when talking about
limitations there is something big in
C++ which creates some heart sings
and that's templates you will see also
template instantiations in C++ in sites
so you get a better claims on what types
are what instantiation of a function are
instantiated in the compiler that does
not necessarily mean that all of them
survive until the end of the compile
stage the linkers and optimizes are able
to throw things away but they are
created at some point in my experience
clang is so smart that it does not
bother to create template instantiations
four types that are not used so that's a
nice effect you can see there which type
is used to which type is not used and
what templates bringing which makes it
hard to generate correct code here if
you look at this example I have here
this function template called func and
it has one template parameter and type T
and after they add I declare a class
demo
and then in main I call func
with demo pasts parameter if you look at
this and C++ insides
and if I do transform this then we can
see here the resulting general template
instantiation of funk for demo here
after my class demo
and that's the reason why this code
would not compile that's the reason why
it's guarded by this if deaf insides use
template so you can define it if you
like to see what's going on but the
default it's disabled and the reason is
when this template instantiation is
parsed by the compiler after this
transformation there is no class demo
there is no type demo in the type system
because demo is declared afterwards okay
so without this if they've guard that
code would not compile I can of course
by hand move that class team around put
it before the function and then it would
compile the reason is that I'm really
easy on generating this template
instantiation they are inserted directly
after the primary template and that may
be the wrong point so one possibility
would be trying to figure out where is
the right place to place it I haven't
checked that deeply there are other
things so you cannot have a template
specialist specialization in a class so
I have had to move things out and I
haven't done this yet so it's just
instantiating at the point where the
primary template is declared
the project itself it's still under
active development so not all statements
are transformed yet there is a pull
request or not pull request
unfortunately not an issue open for
supporting C++ 20s cortines if you have
inside so experience without I'm happy
if you can share them now I said that
C++ incites uses the abstract syntax
tree of the compiler and I like to give
you a feeling what's there is that's
part of an AST of a C++ program and it's
only the last fragment maybe 1% of the
whole aced he floating over mine screen
when I'm dumping this ast and the reason
for that is that this program uses parts
of the standard library and it involves
a lot of template instantiations and
Arliss inks created in the background so
the AST output is very large if you
submit an issue your port for C++
insights I'm very happy if you can't
avoid using the standard library not
because I dislike it but it makes it
really hard to see through all that
sings what's the C++ code behind this
ast what's roughly the program that this
ast models sorry
yes its main saying see out hello C++ so
over the time my crew to being more
fluently in reading the ast output one
word about this talk as we progress it's
a bit special because I today try to
reach two parties one our teachers
because one aspect of creating C++
insights was for teaching and still is
for teaching so I will show you some
examples in C++ which I'm really sure
that you're already familiar with so you
know what they are doing and so on the
purpose of that is just to give you some
glimpse into what is C++ insights able
to show you with things you already know
the other part is to address a little
bit the interest of experts so I have
some C++ 17 some C++ 20 things in there
which I assume not everybody is already
familiar with starting with something
more or less trivial I stumbled over
this during the development because it
worked just out of the box when I
implemented something and that's default
arguments I believe everybody knows what
default arguments do in this case I have
this function here func
which has one parameter X and it has a
default argument 23 so whenever I call
thunk without an argument X is 23 but
how does this work I mean for us it's
easy as programmers developers for a
compiler and never question that it's
just syntactic sugar saying hey you gave
me a function with a default argument
the value is 23 whenever I approach a
function of that type without an
argument I put in
23 as a parameter so functions with
default arguments are not so special at
least if you are not a compiler
implementer
in C++ today we have a lot of different
ways to initialize an object or type
there is an entire one or one and a half
hour talk by Timo dimmler just
explaining the different ways of
initializing something in C++ it's an
excellent talk if you haven't seen it or
heard about it go check it out on
YouTube he gave it a sing at meeting C++
last year and at CPP on seed this year
I'm not talking the rest of this talk
about initialization it's just a small
part here of an example of four char
array of size five and four different
ways initializing them the first one we
had all the time it's an uninitialized
array doing nothing it's always nice
that we can have two things
performance-critical and we know what we
are doing I prefer not to have
uninitialized variables anyway the
second uses c++ Elevens prays the
initialization requesting a zero or
default initialization now when teaching
that even to experience c++ 98
programmers some of them say well i like
to see the value that thing is
initialized with so I prefer version
number 3 stating explicitly I'm
initializing this with 0 I don't know if
that ever happened to you or if you have
a sore thumb singing 1/4 vu and there's
a not a party saying well we are not
initializing sings to 0 we chose 77 so
that's way number 4 let's have a look
if I transform this then of course we
see a not nothing it's uninitialized to
initializes all elements of that array
with zero or an equivalent to zero
because we are talking about the char
here that's nice it do not need to know
- sighs I don't know how often I had to
type a mem set in the past - to
initialize and such things so it's
really nice to be able to just put in
there empty curly braces then version
number three it looks a little bit
different because the first zero is
different than yeras they're all result
to be zero but the first one we can see
is the integer zero we put in there to
initialize what some people think the
whole array with but here we can see
only the first element is initialized
with this zero and the rest is filled
with the zero or default initialization
of that type and that's the reason why
of course number four does not turn out
how it's supposed to be because as soon
as we specify a value we initialize only
dead element the first element of that
array so it's not hard if you think
about it because how would you otherwise
initialize an array with values but it
sometimes confuses people and that it
helped me in the past to show and prove
to them why it is different
yes
it's okay the question is do the curly
praises also burbot the narrowing
conversions which they usually do and
what's happening if I putting a larger
well you're there then the the answer is
it will fail so because it's it's in
this early stage of the the front-end I
only can transfer form compiling code in
C++ inside so I don't know whether the
question was about language or about the
tool the language will not allow it and
the compiler will fail early so I cannot
do a transformation and it shows the
right thing it does nothing
yeah it did to be fair that the compiler
gives you a warning about that yeah I
also print out the compiler warnings so
it's the same thing you would get if you
just compile this example with GCC or
clang and I'm also not sure if I would
be able to transform this what should I
show there did the error message just
comment okay okay so alright okay you
couldn't see that perfect another thing
because I teach a lot of classes to
people who would like to learn C++ 11 14
17 we got this new feature in class
member initialization if you are not a
small example a class called init which
has a default constructor and three
members one end stood vector of end and
stood string in my default constructor
I'm initializing the nth member i-29 and
then I'm using in class member
initialization later to initialize all
the three members to some values I like
0 1 2 3 and hello
and if I do try transform this then we
can see you what magic happens here it's
once again just syntactic sugar they
compile it as fuss
so the inline initialization values we
provided the compiler chest moves into
the default constructor and it's
initializing the stood vector with one
two three and my stood string with hello
so what's happening there is nothing
special we it's the code we can write
ourselves but so we cannot forget it
and one question sometimes comes up is
what happens to I how often is I
initialized and the answer is just once
either with the value I provided in the
default constructor or any other
constructor if you're looking in another
constructors in my case 9 and if I would
totally skip providing that value then
the default would take place in its 0 so
there is no double initialization or
things like that
it's either the value I provided as a
default or the specific value I provide
in a constructor and that's one of the
parts where I experienced it it helps
that people can play around with these
things they can fill in values to can
take off values and they see how it
results in their output
another big thing in C++ these days are
lambdas so here I have an example I've
showed in my talk yesterday already have
a comp char array named hello is the
string how I am to see tech town in it
and then I have a lambda which captures
by reference
they are string and prints it out in a
printf let's have a look what the
compiler generates for us for this
lambda what is the lambda R in C++ we
can't see some side-effect of C++
insides it tells you the size of the
array because it's known at this moment
so even if you haven't specified it at
the right if the left then our lambda is
in fact the Clair's the closure type of
lambda is a class and the compiler
generates this class for us and it takes
care of all the captures because the
captures become members in that class
that's why I have here and count jar a
of references of size 19 to capture the
char string from outside next to that I
have this member function which is a
call operator and this collaborator
contains the body I wrote for the lambda
here so it's just moved to here into the
call operator and this call operators
then called or invoked later when I
invoke the lambda
if I change my capture by reference for
example to capture by copy then we can
see that now I have a char a Const our
array of size 19 and no longer an array
of references and if I say now that this
lambda should be able to alter that
captured string if a close look on the
call operator if I'm saying that that
thing is mutable the count specifier of
the call operator goes away so that's
how things work there I really like it
because it uses facilities already
available in the language and just with
some fantastic sugar and probably a lot
of implementation effort in the compiler
side we can use these nice things and
create existing code sure yes
sure remind me to not do it twice
because I have a slide later but it's an
excellent point here as well with C++ 17
we got implicitly context parameters as
a language feature and that means that
at least for my understanding in the
clang implementation whenever they see a
collaborator in C++ 17 mode while
parsing your C++ code they add context /
to it because it can't be context / and
later on after processing or after
having generated a ast doing the real
compiled stuff they evaluating the body
of the call operator checking whether or
not it satisfies the requirements of
context / if it turns out that yes it
satisfies the requirements of context
Perkins extra stays if it turns out that
no there is something not allowed in
there for context / they just take away
the context / specify and evaluate the
function at compile time because it
makes no sense to promote that to the
user because we didn't explicitly
specify that it should be context / so
they have the Liberty to do it either
way and that's why at this stage I
cannot tell you reliably where I at sing
is context for not what you will see
there if I switch back from C++ 20 to
let's say C + + 14 mode the context
prayers gone because to compile and no
longer inserts it so I've tried to show
only the things to paste he gives me I
have to sketch some things up for
example name of the lander compiler does
not need to generate one for it
internally so I make one up but in
general I try to stick really close to
the ast and that's why this is in
context but to give you a clue it can be
context / but sorry I cannot tell you
for sure that it is I haven't found a
way maybe to trigger the the evaluation
machinery to get to result earlier
and are a small example I have this main
function here and it creates a variable
named collection out of a type which
seems to be a class template X
instantiated with int and then I have
three different for loops
range based for loops which iterate over
that collection this code compiles my
question to you is which of these three
range space for loops are correct in the
sense that they are doing what they are
supposed to do just give me a number
from 0 to 3 you're saying to if any are
a number then to
one two is the correct answer
let's have a look at this so the first
range based full loop says that the
range initializer is of type Const X
Const int and this is not the type we
used before when we declared collection
so it is obviously wrong the second one
and Yarra hand uses Const X int that's
exactly the type as we given it before
when we declared collection so that one
is correct and the end we have the third
version which uses auto and of course
order does the right sing so full of
number two and three are correct one is
the odd one do we all agree well boy you
should have asked me for the
documentation about that sing
so this is the code and if I scroll down
here then at the bottom I will find my
range bass for loops so first I have the
declaration of my variable collection
and then we can see here this opening
and closing scope that's a range bass
full loop range bass foolish generate a
new scope for us and in the odd state
the clearway range variable begin and
end and then they use a regular for to
check Vera we already reached the end
and if not of course the body is called
and then they use the pre increment
operator to increment begin which takes
a lot of performance issues from us this
our variable X which we requested in the
range space for loop and it's
initialized with calling begin and for
that the dereference operator looks good
doesn't it let's have a look at range
base full of number two it's the same
except that for the initialization we
get here what appears to be a
constructor call so it still begin one
that operator star so it still begin you
referenced but then there's a
constructor happening creating that
object for us let's have a look at the
auto case Auto does it the same way as
our first range space full of which
appeared so odd because we specified
that axis of different type because of
the Const then how we initially declared
collection and why is that because of
that because the iterator which is
returned from X is of type X Const
whatever type you passed in first
so the iterator which is returned for
the range space for loop from that type
X is not the original type X it's a
Const version of that original type
Garlin template parameter and why I'm
telling you this
who knows good map yeah the key of stood
map is Const however when you are
creating a stood map we are saying
something like int comma stood string if
you're iterating over a stood map then
this is exactly the trap we can run into
because what's returned there has a
constant key so the first element
becomes constant and that's why some of
us that why is that you should always
prefer Const here because it does the
right thing by default or ask and look
at the documentation
while we're talking about range space
for loops are really like them and I'm
super happy about them and try to apply
them wherever I can and some things that
make me sad are things like that here a
half example we have a stood vector and
I'd like to iterate over that vector and
print the elements out but to get out
with that I like to print the index at
which that element is in a vector and
doing that and need some help a variable
ID X to have the index countered and
incremented and that wearable ID X now
is outside of the range space for loop
and with that it's leaking in the
adjacent scope and it isn't so beautiful
anymore
it's one thing about arranged based full
loops that everything is tightly
together and for that case I have to do
something different well I can use this
to the algorithm for example for each
pass in a Lam they are doing the out
sing but then still the ITX variable has
to be somewhere so same pain at least if
you like to see the code like me the
good message is in C++ 20 we will have
range based foo loops with initializes
which enables me to write code like this
and now can say for paren open so I see
RDX semicolon and then the rest of the
former range based for loop and with
that it's again tightly coupled if you
look at what's happening there and C++
insides it's again surprisingly easy
here we have the opening scope of the
range space full loop and after that our
variable is 2 cleared so it's only
visible in that scope and will be
destroyed later yes
so the question is can I have an
arbitrary number of initializations like
like this that was not possible before
and the language rules didn't change
there so it's it's not what you are so
the question is if I get it right can
can I say something like this stead
right and to my knowledge that wasn't
possible ever before in a usual four
loop the compiler says that with this
comma separation there is only one
declaration allowed so that the first
type has to be you cannot have aa you're
asking about multiple semicolons and
didn't get that no you cannot have that
so it's once again a little syntactic
sugar and if I took it right from the
notes it was also already not that
trivial for some compiler vendors to
implement it so that's what we are
having so it's just a single type so
transaction is you can use a tuple to
hack around a toast to the very end oh
yeah whatever you need
I lied a little bit to you before
because there is a way to get what I
like
without C++ twenties range based for
loops which initializers I can use for
example mustard for each algorithm and
use C++ for teens in it capture to
introduce a new variable called ID X in
that lambda which is of size T and
default initialized so it's how we can
put the pieces together
that's simple as plus 14th lambdas
extension in C++ 17 we got a little
extension to variadic templates we can
now apply parameter packs together with
using and what is this is enables us to
have inline number for this using TS
call operator dot dot dot sing what
we're looking at a very attic class
template which takes an arbitrary number
of types and derives from each of them
and this using statement says that from
each of these types please drag in the
coal operators all we have into the
overload struct so that they are
accessible Nico had an excellent example
how to apply that in a bigger context
yesterday in his talk if you've been
there and not just check out the video
what a thing does now is I can use this
together with a deduction guide which
you can see in line 79 and use it in
line 13 to create struct which contains
multiple Landers if you like or it
derives me
from multiple lambdas in my case - Wanda
takes an INT by reference and the second
one that takes in double by reference
first one multiplies the past value by
two the second one by 2.0 and it has
also a second variable which is
multiplied by two again and now I can
use this greater type double dbl to
either call it with one parameter in
line 21 or with two in line 22 looking
at what's going on there we can now see
an order template instantiation here our
class overload gets instantiated with
two different lambdas two ones I created
they used to derive from them publicly
and this is the part where my using with
the operator dot o dot comes in now I
have using declaration for both
operators of both lambdas operators of
both lambdas because it might help C++
insights gives you here as a comment the
full signature of the collaborator you
got from the type so from the first
lambda and for the second one which can
help you to figure out why things go not
as expected probably and then down here
we can see of course the lambda as we've
seen it before then here our overload is
created with the two lambdas and while I
prepare this Turk I discovered something
I didn't expect and I have no answer to
so far here's the first call calling
that created object dbl with just a
single hour
it's an INT there the call operator on
double is called while in line below for
to me so far unknown reason this dbl
variable is casted to the type of the
lambda so the compiler at this point
seems to know better what to do and then
it invokes the call operator I'm not
sure if it's more efficient to do it
that way it was just a breast yes so the
question is if I if that sing would skip
the virtual function dispatching if
there was a where a virtual function and
that's what I saw - yes it's just
because there is no virtual function I'm
not sure if there's more going on I'm
not seeing so maybe it doesn't need to
figure out an address offset or I don't
know for a virtual part it would be
totally and I think that's what make it
first and maybe that's a general
optimization they are doing and if it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it does
not make things worse so maybe that's
the idea here
so what else do we have behalf in C++
70 in a context brave and you may have
heard of that the goal here is that only
one of the SIF branches wives after
parsing it because it's context per all
the orders are discard but all branches
have to be well it that's one rule and
if he once again like to verify that he
has a bit more to code but it's just to
make it compile then we can see below
here we have the primary template which
contains all the branches and then I
have my template specialization which
only contains the Linux branch because I
stated that my native OS currently is
Linux so all the other process go away
but I'm lying I'm on a Mac so if it
changed this then I'm getting an error
but well who likes steady cursors right
so it's right away now what we can see
here is the first Linux branch is empty
it's there but it's empty so it doesn't
bother the compiler and then we have
here now the Mac branch surviving yes
yes thank you that's where I'm getting
so if you are looking closely at this
code we can't see something I didn't
bother with four years with C++ and see
the key here is there is no else if in
C++ there sniff and there's nails but
there's no else if they are languages
like Python bash they have the L if
keyword in C++ we just have a else and
if and that's why I have here a context
per F and the context per else branch
and notice that here opens a new scope
and in that scope is my F because that's
how in C++ and C else if it's modeled
it's just an if inside else and that's
why this marked else if it's not context
per its in regular if with an else
branch within a context for else and if
I add Const X / - that I can
put in the static assert you should not
command out a static assert like I
trusted and then we can't see now I have
only there if branch debt survives there
is no else Prancer anymore
and that's important to know because if
you're not having a static desert there
and not doing a lot of checks it may
slip under the radar so remember to put
on Airy if a context / if you like to
have a context but if even if it's
together we say else that's the takeaway
here ya know that it's something I
created that comes from a knot effect
that if I would use a plane stood the
same or something like this here or the
static assured visitor always true then
it would always trigger because the
branch is always evaluated and if I'm
putting here for example the typical
order problem this static desert is
essentially always true I should never
reach that and it's a context brave so
you might sing sorry I should say it's
always faults but always true and now it
stops compiling because that branch is
evaluated that as soon as we hit that
static hazard it triggers and that's why
I have this this always Falls template
around it but it's not part of the
standard library I think yet I have my
own implementation yes because now that
static Azure depends on the template
parameter and that's why it is discard
later and not triggers yeah
so with c++ 17 we got our nice tools we
can now use auto together as a non type
template parameter which enables me to
write code like this I have this print
function which is a template and I can
now say here the first parameters of
type auto and name its app for separator
and its default initialized with space
and after that not a template parameter
comes and then there comes an arbitrary
number of template parameters because
it's a very etic template now I can use
this first argument this auto non type
template parameter to use it as a
separator to insert between each of
their arguments to separator and that I
can then use to print out hello C++ 20
nice and easy
if I am look at this
C++ insights we can see what's happening
there compiler grades a bunch of
template instantiations for us first we
have a print version with all of the
elements or all of the arguments passed
in because it's a constant Bri if I have
this terminating case here then there is
a version where one argument is popped
and there's the last version there only
one argument remains and that's how I
terminate this recursion so here if a
recursion but that's one way how you can
apply this context brief but see Blas
+17 gave her something more we got fault
expressions there so I can change this
example slightly applying Lam there's
not a liked feature together is fault
expressions to achieve the same thing
and if I now transform this again
then we can see first of all I only get
one instantiation for print because I
have no recursion anymore and it has all
the parameters of course it creates a
temp lambda which contains my C out here
and what we are looking here at is a
generic lambda which we got with C++ 14
and now we can see there they are
generic lambda this Auto keyword we can
apply here results in our call operator
and the lambda being just a template and
my order parameter is now a template
parameter or template argument depending
on when you're looking at it and that's
why I'm getting in this lambda to more
instantiation one taking reference to
conjure array and another one
taking conference to an int because
that's how I call a lambda and then
below here we can see what default
expression does it just comma separate
it's d calls to the lambdas call
operator
once again syntactic sugar just to
enable us to write less code and better
code
okay we already talked about context
parameters so we can sleep this if you
like the project you can support a
project my favorite sport number one is
go to get up pick an issue and give me a
pull request also very favorable is if
you find a bug file an issue I also like
that all the great support if you more
on the hey I have a lot of money to give
you side
aside from hiring me for training
classes you can support me at pet run
with small amounts of memory and the
project with that if you like to be more
on the side I like to show then maybe
Spreadshirt t-shirts was to C++ inside
slow who are the right thing for you all
that helps to fund the servers and all
the stuff that sing runs on some time
ago when I tweeted about a new feature I
got this tweet back which seems to come
from somebody which is able to speak
English and German now the question was
so it's completely Phatak and the answer
is no you don't think so it's the start
of journey um there are a lot of C++ 20
things to implement guess not all things
are already implemented and there are
most likely some issues so it's a good
point but it's it's not ant with all
that sad it's been a pleasure giving the
talk to you today I have just three warm
words for you and that's I am fetish
[Applause]